So you wanna cause a little mischief, do you?
Here are 6 easy pranks to help you on your
way.
#6
You can prank someone who watches a lot of
TV with one simple trick. Just look on the
front of the remote for a little LED like
this, and cut a small piece of black electrical
tape about the same shape. When you smooth
it down over the LED it will hardly be noticeable
at all. Now when your victim goes to use their
remote, they'll be frustrated and confused
by why it doesn't work anymore, even after
they change out the batteries.
#5
Carefully remove the lid to the toilet tank,
and pour in 10 - 20 drops of food coloring.
Replace the lid, and now the next time your
victim goes to flush, they'll get an unexpected
surprise. There's a good chance the next person
in the bathroom will be a little concerned
as well.
#4
This little prank, is on your local drive
through. Follow the link in the description
to download and print off this sign, then
cut along the dotted line at the bottom. Now
simply add some tape, and post it near the
microphone on the drive through station. You
can get a lot of people to fall for this one
because the signature makes the notice seem
authentic.
#3
If you dig through your pile of junk mail,
chances are you'll find one of these business
reply envelopes. The return postage is paid
by the advertising companies, so why not load
the envelope with your junk mail, and send
it back? You'll cut down on garbage, and this
joke, will be at their expense.
#2
This prank works best with a bunch of bananas.
Look for any natural brown spots on the peels
where you can push in a pin without the hole
being noticed. Rock the pin side to side a
few times, then repeat the process all the
way up the banana, spacing the holes about
an inch apart. Now the next time someone goes
to eat one of these delicious pieces of fruit,
they'll be shocked to see it's already sliced
into bite sized pieces. Just tell them it's
probably a new brand that's been genetically
modified.
#1
Ask someone to try an experiment that will
test their coordination. When they agree,
see if they can hold a half full plastic cup
with just their teeth. Next, have them place
both arms out in front of them with their
palms facing down and tell them to balance
two more cups on the backs of their hands.
Now just walk away.
Well there are a few ides to help get you
started on your quest for making mischief.
If you liked this project, perhaps you'll
like some of my others. Check them out at
www.thekingofrandom.com